Michael have you ever had a
disappointing audition that actually led
to acting work and also vice versa one
where you nailed it and you never heard
back
oh god yeah the second one that you said
happens all the time to me but my first
Lauren order appearance I thought I
bombed the audition I went in there I
was nervous was my first audition for
them in New York and i reaiiy went in I
was nervous I what I was prepared but it
was just way nervous because it's my
first time in front of these people
and I left the audition and I actually
called my my parents and I was like I
bombed it this is awful I was like
depressed for like like you know like
the next few hours like this is terrible
like why what am i doing is my first
like you know here in New York trying to
act trying to you know be an actor and I
kind of call the next day and they're
like you booked they love you and I
didn't understand I was like what what
is this what is this business you know
and it's like they were actually looking
for a nervous young police officer to
play the role I guess that's what I came
off as so they booked me insane and I
and I was able to do he was a principal
role with Jeremy Sisto and Anthony and
ourselves my first principal role on the
TV show ridiculous story so from that
day what is that that must have changed
your whole perception about oh yeah life
and just you don't know you just you be
prepared as much as you can you go in
these rooms and you do your best you
never know what they're looking for
because there have been auditions when
I've been so prepared maybe even over
prepared crush the audition and they're
like they are looking for a black guy or
you're you know what that you were not
Latino enough so you here's what you can
control in that room and this is a good
tip for actors you can only control what
you can control which is your acting
talent you can't worry about how tall
you are you can't worry if your eyes are
the right color you go in there and you
make a fan you go in there and you try
and do the best work that you can you
know that that's that's all you can do
and there have been multiple times this
past pilot season I had some amazing
callbacks some of the best auditions
I've had in Los Angeles thus far and
yeah in book it but after I got that
call for my management's I didn't book
it it bothered me for about five minutes
and I was like I can't be upset there
was nothing else I could do there was
nothing else no other acting choices I
could have made that could have you know
got me the role or not gotten me the
role it was the best that I could do and
that was a good feeling actually it was
actually a good feeling it was like you
know what they missed out who ever you
know didn't book me it's like I did my
best and that's all that's all you can
do is your best but make sure you're
doing your best cuz you know you know
when you're not doing your best you know
when your work is like you were
underprepared you flubbed a line because
you weren't really off-book you got to
go in there and be a hundred percent
confident that you're giving your best
because guess what if you're not the
next guy is and that's the guy that's
gonna book the role what's being
over-prepared oh rehearsing the scene
too much that's happened to me before
for my auditions I get an acting coach I
hire I have two acting coaches I work
with for every single other should I go
on and there are times when I go in
there and and I'm ready to work with
them and I'm over prepared to rehearsed
where it's not organic you know you
could that there's being off-book is
great you know but being off-book to the
point where you're not anticipating or
you're anticipating the other person's
lines is no bueno
it's got to be organic so you know if I
read that script a billion times and did
the sign the scene with you a billion
times when I get to the audition it's
gonna look robotic it's not gonna be
fresh and fun and it's what they want
you know they want a fresh fun
compelling scene so if I throw out a
line could you omit mcwhat over-prepared
was down like like honey how was work no
it's more like if you said that line to
me and I responded in organically like
said honey it was great oh that doesn't
work because you don't even get to
finish your sentence
that's being a prepared okay you know
what he means yes good analogy okay
you